[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
carrie underwood is reaching new heights
literally
i'm doing things that i have never done
before while singing the 39 year old
singer has the crowd in awe with her
aerial talent at the cmt music awards on
monday during her performance of ghost
story
[Music]
underwood begins a song on a raised
platform later joining her dancers in
the performance delivering the last
lines of the emotional track
[Music]
the pre-recorded performance was filmed
at the resort's world theater home of
carrie's las vegas residency
backstage at the award show carrie
spills to e.t how they came up with the
idea to incorporate the aerial stunt we
have
these incredible aerialists and dancers
in our show in vegas at reflection and
they were so inspiring and i was like i
wonder if i could do that and i have the
song ghost story and i feel like well if
there's a song to try it on it's this
one so i i worked with our director and
choreographer brenda and
we had a couple
sessions and i was like hey i'm not too
bad and after completing her second sold
out show the singer will continue
another round of dates beginning in may
which she teased during the cmt
rehearsals we put a lot of hard work a
lot of love
the show is high energy we packed it
full of hits so hopefully people can
just come and sing along to their
favorite songs and um just have fun it's
vegas baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
back in nashville kerry's celebrating
big she and jason aldean took home two
awards for their hit if i didn't love
you collaborative video of the year and
the biggest honor of the night video of
the year
jason l dean and carrie underwood
this one's all about the fans vansa
thank you fans thank you cmt
it's just a great night all around i
mean obviously the winds um i have the
most amazing fans in the world and i
feel like my fans and jason's fans just
like united and just gave us super
powers for them
these two cmt trophies bring carrie's
collection to a whopping 25.
but for jason this big win
well it's an extra special milestone
17 years in the game this is the first
time i've ever won video of the year so
this is pretty amazing for me
i think kerry and i kind of hit the
scene about the same time and the fact
that you guys still care enough about us
this this many years in our career to
vote for us and um
and care enough about what we're doing
to to still love the music and listen to
it vote for us means
the world to me to have it with the have
it be with jason aldean um it's just
extra special because i feel like two of
us get to celebrate um the song that
we're so proud of the video that we're
so proud of